This video is for anyone that's been banned from mid-journey or doesn't want to get banned
from mid-journey and at the end of the video I'll point you to 16 great alternatives.
Hi, I'm Api Dave and I'm going to share what happened.
The ban that I got, the $300 that I lost, what I believe is a misdiagnosis and the frustration
that I had dealing with mid-journey support.
And then after that I'm going to show you 16 beautiful alternatives to mid-journey.
I've been using mid-journey since March last year and I've created thousands of images
that I've used a lot within my YouTube videos.
But last year I did end up switching a fair bit over to Dali 3 mainly because I found
it easier to work with within ChatGPT and I'd already done a video showcasing 200 image
comparisons between the two different products across 50 prompts.
And in my opinion, Dali 3, while not as good as mid-journey, was a worthy contender.
Last month I was talking at a tech summit and I needed some pretty good images for the
presentation I was doing so I ended up reactivating my mid-journey account.
Now one week later I found myself having to upgrade because I'd used up all the credits
that I had there and I ended up spending $288.
But it was great because the images I was able to generate for the tech summit presentation
were just wonderful.
Now two weeks ago I moved to countries, I came over to Thailand and not long after arriving
I started getting this particular error creation failed on my mid-journey account.
I headed over to Discord and saw this error that's saying accessing our services via
automation, scripting or third party tools created a ban.
Now I started doing a bit of research to figure out what was going on because I hadn't done
any automation or third party scripting and people had come up with these issues banned
due to billing not matching the home address okay, not my situation.
Someone has talked about losing a $60 subscription and not being refunded.
My situation is $288 because I spent it for a full year and I haven't been refunded either.
Then we saw other sorts of issues with banning going on and then this next one gave me a
little bit of a clue to what might be the issue.
This includes IP and email bans from Discord.
I headed over to an email and I wrote I can't sign into mid-journey I've checked the images
there's nothing that meets the fraud or the other issues that they listed.
I'm an influencer and basically all the images that I do for YouTube and that's important
to understand because you can't do bad quality images on YouTube and get away with it.
And what happened was I got this reply straight away from them saying severe repeated violations
of terms and services, use of automation, scripting, APIs, engaging in reselling services.
So none of this stuff was going on for me.
And then we had this one.
You should have received notifications in Discord informing you of this that they would
have appeared that you've interacted with a bot and copies should have been sent to you.
Now I've not received a direct message regarding that so I'm not sure what's going on.
The other thing that they've stated here is as per the terms and conditions refunds are
not issued on banned accounts.
So I thought okay where do I go now?
So as I reviewed the forums again it got me thinking about this IP address ban and the
reason it got me thinking about it is that a year and a half ago I came to Chiang Mai for six months
and while I was here I signed up to an American e-commerce platform.
About two weeks later they sent me an email saying that I've been banned and that I've
been banned for life.
I could not get an account again and I ended up in that particular situation sending details
of my passport and my bank account details.
And then funnily enough four months later when I was back in Australia I got a reversal.
So that was a misdiagnosis going on.
Now two weeks ago I found myself moving again back to Chiang Mai and I was going via the Philippines.
So the three places that I find myself in are Australia where I'm either in Sydney or Brisbane.
I find myself in Philippines and I find myself in Thailand.
I ended up sending a reply email to mid-journey stating that I hadn't violated any terms or
conditions that I was aware of and that I travel and that means that I open on different
computers with different IPs my mid-journey account and all they did was reply stating
we can't provide you with any additional information about your ban.
Banned users are not eligible for a refund.
So to be honest I was a bit gutted by all of that and quite angry that I'd spent money
only about three weeks earlier and it was all lost and they won't even do the courtesy of
communicating with me about it.
Rather than get caught up in the resentment of dealing with mid-journey support what I
thought is it's time for a new relationship.
Now here are 16 great alternatives to mid-journey and if you've got any questions about them then
please drop a comment down below otherwise like and subscribe because the next video
I'm going to go into detail on these 16 image generators and how they compare
to the same prompt in mid-journey.